Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Michelangelo Bardella
Ciao a tutti.
Quando ero al liceo, mi sentivo sola.
Non parlavo con i miei genitori,
non parlavo nemmeno
con i miei compagni di classe.
Nell’estate tra il primo e il secondo anno
delle superiori conosco un ragazzo.
Lui è quattro anni più grande di me,
vive in un’altra città,
ma nonostante questo decidiamo comunque
di iniziare questa relazione.
Purtroppo nessuno mi aveva mai insegnato
cosa fosse una relazione sana.
E, per questo, non riuscii
a cogliere all’inizio i segnali
che questa non lo fosse affatto.
È proprio in questo momento
che inizio a sviluppare i primi sintomi
del disturbo da stress post traumatico,
perché alcune esperienze
erano state affrettate
e non riuscivo a gestirne
il peso psicologico da sola.
In questo momento, inizio
anche a disegnare:
ci sono i quadretti sotto,
perché disegnavo sui banchi di scuola.
In quarta superiore
conosco un altro ragazzo.
Spero che con lui i sintomi migliorino,
ma invece cado in un altro circolo
di abusi sia emotivi sia fisici.
La nostra relazione era
una sorta di “fungo velenoso”,
che mi proliferava nel cuore.
In questo periodo smetto di scrivere,
smetto di disegnare;
I pochi disegni che faccio non parlano,
è come se fossero vuoti, senz’anima.
Finalmente mi trasferisco a Bolzano
per iniziare l’università:
conosco altre persone,
riesco a ritagliarmi uno spazio
in cui riesco a non vivere
questa relazione tossica.
Lui non la prende molto bene.
Le poche volte che viene a trovarmi
a Bolzano, mi fa sentire
il suo possesso con altri abusi.
A un certo punto decido
che non ce la faccio più
e inizio a parlare
della mia storia a un amico,
che poi diventerà il mio ragazzo.
In questo momento capisco che,
quelle che per me erano storie normali
perché c’ero dentro e le stavo vivendo,
a un orecchio esterno
erano invece delle storie allucinanti.
Inizio piano piano a scoprire
questo potere di comunicare
la mia storia agli altri.
Quindi...
scusatemi!
[Applauso]
E scopro una cosa molto importante:
che la solitudine non è una condizione
obbligatoria e, a differenza di quello
che avevo creduto per anni,
non era una cosa che mi meritavo.
Però, durante la pandemia,
durante il lockdown,
inizio a essere costretta,
insieme a molti altri di voi,
a un differente tipo di solitudine.
In questo momento decido
di riprendere in mano la matita
e decido di iniziare
a fare questi disegni,
che poi posto sui social,
in cui descrivo come mi sento:
descrivo la mia tristezza,
la mia solitudine e la mia storia.
Nel frattempo, però,
la mia situazione mentale
inizia a peggiorare,
perché i sintomi del disturbo
da stress post traumatico
iniziano a farsi sentire di nuovo:
ho flashback continui, ansia,
attacchi di panico,
misto ad episodi depressivi
in cui davvero non riuscivo
ad alzarmi dal letto.
Ricordandomi l’esperienza
che avevo vissuto
parlandone con un mio amico,
decido che forse questa cosa
di parlarne con qualcuno può farmi bene
e quindi decido di andare da un terapeuta,
e poi successivamente da uno psichiatra.
Il problema è che facevo
davvero tanta fatica
a parlare dei miei traumi,
a parlare della mia storia.
Probabilmente questo non era
il modo migliore per me,
la parola non era quello
che mi faceva stare meno male.
In università arriva
l’occasione perfetta, diciamo, per me,
perché, durante un progetto universitario,
mi viene chiesto di progettare
qualcosa con il tema della cura.
In quel momento mi viene
questa idea e dico:
“Ok, la cura non è
come ce la presentano sempre,
non è una passeggiata
in mezzo alla natura,
non è un bagno caldo.”
Forse sì, è anche quello, però la cura
che stavo affrontando io in quel momento
era un percorso di dolore, di fatica,
ed era davvero tanto impegnativo per me.
Allora decido di associare
alla parola cura la parola taglio.
Inizio ad analizzare i vari significati
della parola “tagliare”,
perché quello che avevo fatto io
era tagliare i contatti
con una relazione tossica.
Ad esempio: ritagliare le foto,
quello che magari si fa di istinto
quando ci lasciamo con una persona.
Oppure mescolare il mazzo,
dividere il mazzo delle opportunità
che ci possono capitare nella vita.
Ad esempio, a me, per fortuna,
è capitata l'occasione
di poter tagliare la corda, di nuovo,
e poter fuggire a Bolzano.
Quando invio la bozza del libro
all’editore non ci credo per niente.
Però succede che l’editore mi consiglia
di pubblicarlo, decide di pubblicarlo.
A questo punto, portando il libro
in giro per le fiere,
parlandone con gli altri,
anche la mia storia mi diventa più chiara,
e forse anche un po’ più sopportabile.
Adesso, anni dopo
le prime esperienze che ho fatto
e le prime esperienze
di relazione tossica,
ho un libro che mi guarda dalla libreria,
ed è una cosa che ancora faccio
tanta fatica a realizzare.
Pubblicare questo libro per me
ha significato tantissimo.
Per me è stata la logica conseguenza
di averne prima parlato a un amico,
poi aver contattato un terapeuta
e poi aver trovato finalmente
quello che per me è la mia cura,
cioè il fumetto.
Poter esprimermi attraverso il disegno,
attraverso la scrittura.
Quello che invito anche voi a fare
è trovare un qualsiasi
mezzo per esprimervi,
perché avete il diritto
di esprimere la vostra storia
attraverso il disegno, l’arte, la musica,
quello che più preferite.
In questo modo, non solo quello
che avete vissuto
forse assumerà un significato,
ma forse vi aiuterà anche a curarvi,
a poter riuscire
ad accettare quegli episodi
della vita che forse vorremmo dimenticare.
Grazie.
[Applausi]